yes hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number
one97 I am Dr Brett Weinstein this is Dr
Heather Hine uh no I did not stumbl on
your name I stumbled on whether or not
to say the next thing and it just
happened to come right before I
delivered your name but believe me your
name I got this one wired I can't even
spell it yeah I know I I know yeah um
yeah so anyway we are here at your
timing at the at the
intentional halting nature of the timing
which is actually an indicator that
things are very far off in the universe
and that I am doing extra processing so
that I do not end up um removed from the
discussion indeed yes here we are 197
197 prime prime number prime number you
can look for factors as much as you want
you're not going to find them there are
two and we know what they are indeed
uh please join us on Rumble uh and if
you're watching live at the watch party
at locals uh join us at locals anyway
we've got a private Q&A that we just did
a couple days ago we're going to do some
amas from our travels upcoming I think
at least one um this is the last live
stream that we're going to have for a
little over three weeks actually we're
not going to be back until until
November but there will be some amazing
guest episodes uh dropping on Dark Horse
between now and then uh and after
immediately after today's live stream we
will do a Q&A going to have to keep it a
little bit brief but uh we're going to
do that and um today we're going to talk
about some of the stuff that is going on
in the world as we always do my goodness
um one thing to say more before we go on
to our sponsors is that we've got some
great new uh merchandise at our great
new store we've talked before about
Jake's micro Pizza I will which is
delicious as I keep pointing at it's
really it's not the only selling point
point but it is one of them I will put
on my mask when I'm done eating yes uh
but we also have now blueberries because
oxidant happen yep um I'm really I'm
thrilled with this we have we work with
this just wonderful wonderful artist and
uh he created this from an idea that
Brett had many many many years ago I
wanted to create something of this sort
for the longest time and uh I have I
have lived to see it you have you have
lived to see it congratulations so
that's at I don't even have the store
dark hor store.org dark Darkhorse
store.org uh you can get those and uh
and Jake's micro pizza and all the rest
epic Tabby direwolves um fizer where the
breakthroughs never
stop one of my favorites actually in
light of their stock price it's a good
it's a good week to remind people about
fizer's role in the world yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you can get that and more at
Darkhorse store.org uh but for now uh
before we launch into the main part of
the podcast we have as usual three
sponsors right at the top uh we choose
them carefully we say no to many who
approach us um just because um they're
not a fit or we don't we don't feel like
we can really be honestly vouching for
their products or their services um so
you know that if you are hearing us talk
about it and um and we do we we provide
absolutely zero sponsored content except
for uh these three ads at the top of our
at the top of the show if you're
watching you will always see that green
perimeter on the screen when we are
beating ads and the beginning and the
end of the ads are marked by a tone uh
so that's how you know that we are
reading ads but um they are ones that we
truly truly vouch for so without further
Ado our sponsors this week are the
wellness company Hillsdale College and
unru we are so pleased to have as our
first sponsor this week the wellness
company world-renowned experts like Dr
Peter McCulla have partnered with the
wellness company to create real change
in healthcare they offer a wide variety
of supplements and services including
telea health emergency medical kits
which include icon and teams of medical
professionals that can assist in helping
patients kick the
pharmace assist in helping patients kick
the pharmaceutical habit with their
freedom from Pharma program and I just
there's a hpo in there and little
editing on the Fly here okay um now they
are awesome um the script that I wrote
based on what they sent me not so much
but that has nothing to do with them um
teams of medical professionals as I said
this is the wellness company that can
assist helping patients kick the
pharmaceutical habit
with their program that they call
Freedom from Pharma the wellness company
has all sorts of useful and important
products personally I'm a fan of their
Mito support Mito is in mitochondria
which is formulated to provide energy
both physical and mental and their Spike
support formula is their most popular
product it's useful not only for those
who have been vaccinated but for anyone
who may be suffering from long coid as
well as the wellness company says in the
website if you're looking to quote get
back to that pre-co feeling their Spike
support formula can help Spike support
is made with a combination of natural
ingredients like ninas dandelion root
extract selenium black sativa extract
Irish sea moss and green tea extract
these ingredients all contain immune
boosting capabilities and the nen
specifically has been used by Japanese
people for decades because of its
ability to dissolve blood clots but more
recently narok Kines has been shown to
be able to break down Spike proteins in
the bloodstream and even block them from
binding to cells Dr MCA says quote out
of all the available therapies I've used
in my practice and among all the
proposed detoxification agents I believe
ninas and peptides hold the greatest
promise for patients at this time end
quote whether you've taken the vaccine
or just had coid if you're concerned
about circulating Spike proteins go to
tww c. Health Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to save 15% on your first
order that's TWC stands for the wellness
company tww c. Health Darkhorse and use
code Darkhorse to say 15% off such an
interesting moment that we have people
formulating bad stuff that gets into us
either because it's contagious or
because they injected into you and then
we have other people figuring out uh how
to undo the harm wow didn't not a battle
I saw coming creating antidotes for uh
medicine yeah creating antidotes to
medicine that's an interesting way to
put it and the wellness company is doing
just that our second sponsor this week
is Hillsdale College another kind of
antidote to its existing to this
structure that it appears to be part of
creating an antidote to standard higher
head the gain of function that is Tak
inside the academy oh man um yeah since
1844 Hillsdale Hillsdale College has
been providing an education that focuses
on freedom and character at Hillsdale
they believe that a virtuous citizen is
the best defense for Liberty and now
they've taken some of their core classes
and made them available online for free
for anyone who wants to learn so many
people look back on their college
education whether it was yesterday or
decades ago and wonder what they learned
some people wish they had focused on the
things they were interested in rather
than what they were told they needed for
a successful career hillsdale's new
online courses allow people to do just
that timing technology have changed a
lot of things but they have not changed
basic fundamental truths about the world
and our place in it Hillsdale College's
online courses range widely there are
several on the Constitution and on
Congress the presidency and the Supreme
Court there are great books courses as
well as courses focusing on the works of
CS Lewis Mark Twain Shakespeare and Jane
Austin there are history classes from
ancient Christianity to the rise and
fall of the Roman Republic to the second
world war and even classes on math and
logic from uclid to Modern geometry and
one on the great principles of chemistry
and they've got a few more uh online uh
around um you know what it means to be a
good citizen and uh and and how that has
changed over time which are looking
really interesting there are 39 free
courses to choose from they're
self-paced so you can start whenever you
want you can start right now it's
everything you need all in one place
with no long-term commitment learn when
and where you want enroll now in
Hillsdale is not for credit online
courses program it's free it's fun and
it will change the the way you
understand our country the world and
your place in it go right now to
hillsdale.edu Darkhorse to enroll
there's no cost and it's easy to get
started that's hillsdale.edu Darkhorse
to register once more hillsdale.edu
Darkhorse great moment to take a course
on the Constitution with uh um political
party in power persecuting their enemies
using the courts and then uh getting gag
orders to prevent uh those who are being
persecuted from discussing their
persecution it's uh it's really a moment
to remind yourself of what might be in
that Constitution and what it is
supposed to do to prevent moments like
this it's it would seem that many view
it as a fair weather document to be
invoked only when things are good and no
one really needs its protections very
much yeah it's a parasol not an umbrella
is what they're saying and frankly I
don't think that's true okay our final
sponsor this week is unru small small
ship Adventures uncruise explores by sea
and by land they have boats that hold
orders of magnitude fewer people than
most cruise boats and they take their
passengers to some of the world's most
magnificent places Panama and Costa Rica
Galapagos the Sea of Cortez in Mexico
Alaska and even our own backyard the
sanan islands when UNC Crews first
approached us we were skeptical our
standards for travel and especially
anything bordering on adventure travel
are very high we have years of
experience leading trips to the
scablands of Eastern Washington and the
Columbia River Gorge as well as the uh
Andy and Paro galpagos and the Amazon we
know most trips do not meet expectations
uncrewed in contrast exceeds
expectations spectacularly the small
boats unru uh allow the small boats of
uncruise allow passengers to get real
deep experience their largest boat can
accommodate a mere 86 guests the boats
of UNC crws take small groups of people
to places that larger boats can't go and
excursions are designed to bring people
into deep nature without destroying it
when we spoke to the CEO Dan Blanchard
we discovered that we shared an ethos
the value of wild roadless nature of
exploration and observation we took an
uncruise week-long trip through the
Inland Waters of Southeast Alaska in
early May and were blown away by what we
saw and what we were able to do we saw
sea otters with their pups mountain
goats Eagles in their nests brown and
black bears puffins orcas humpbacks
Arctic turns too many species to list
and mile after mile of the most
breathtaking scenery each day we got off
the boat to hike or kayak and the crew
and naturalist guides were to a person
kind knowledgeable and enthusiastic the
food was surprisingly good and food
preferences and sensitivities were
handled perfectly every sailing with
unru is all inclusive Transportation
drinks Farm totable Cuisine daily
excursions everything is included
uncruise understands that the boat is
just a tool their small ship cruises
take guests through communities and
locals uh on the ground so that they can
have actual experiences unru is giving
Darkhorse listeners a fantastic deal by
500 bucks off their current cruise
current
cruises uh an offer that you can combine
with other offers so start thinking
about winter in the tropics now or
spring trips to Alaska plan a trip with
unru today and take advantage of this
great offer go now to UNC cruise.com
Pages Darkhorse remember to save $500 on
your trip go now UNC
cruise.com Pages Darkhorse again that's
u
ncru i e /pages
Darkhorse
awesome so we're going to spend a little
bit of time first today I think um maybe
largely maybe
entirely
discussing a
un no a wh
document uh that is being proposed to
amend a 2005 uh document that has long
been
in existence which uh John Campbell
awesome John Campbell uh recently did a
20-minute video discussing uh which is
how you came to be aware of it which is
how I came to be aware of it I I was
aware of it before from uh a number of
people's work maril nass included um but
I was
uh drawn rapidly back to a consideration
of where this process was and what its
implications were by John Campbell's
excellent um video in which he largely
turns over the mic to uh a member of um
Parliament I believe in in uh the EU
yeah uh so let's just we're gon to end
up going through this document a bit but
you can show my screen here for a moment
um and this is again out of the who the
World Health Organization an article by
article compilation of proposed
amendments to the international Health
regulations which again were uh official
as of 2005 submitt in accordance with
decision w75 parentheses 9
2022 uh so this is um this document
which we're going to go through some uh
lists not the entire 2005 International
Health regulations uh uh as produced by
The Who uh but just the proposed changes
both deletions and additions uh to those
2005 uh regulations as recently proposed
by uh wh associated countries so I
wanted to say something it's a strange
thing to say in light of the fact that
we haven't even talked about what's here
yet but I want to I'm going to make the
argument that you are supposed to be
having a reaction to this already that
the presentation the name all of it is
supposed to cause you to
think this is boring this is remote this
probably doesn't have a meaning because
the ability of the who to do things that
actually result in some important
distinction in what I do and don't have
to do at home is uh it's pretty unlikely
and so anyway you're supposed to decide
that you don't have the bandwidth for
this because it's probably somebody
else's job you don't have the expertise
it's not interesting and there's too
much going on and that that is masking
what I would argue is one of the two
most important things taking place in
the world at this moment one of them
obviously on every body's mind which is
the crisis in the Middle East and what
implication it has for the globe frankly
um but the other one is this and if that
surprises you that something you may not
have even heard about or if you've heard
about it you've already put it aside
because it doesn't sound important then
you got another thing coming because
what's actually here is um spectacular
in terms of the proposal to planet Earth
that it really proposes yes indeed uh so
let us begin first with just a couple of
statements uh that are in the video that
John cble uh largely shows in this video
so this is a speech by Philip Cruz a
Swiss lawyer who was involved in the
citizens initiative uh reacting to this
at the European he was speaking at the
European Parliament for the uh ECI
citizens initiative to challenge The Who
on their pandemic treaty so I think I
aired I think I said he was a member of
parliament but he's a lawyer speaking in
Parliament yeah he's a lawyer speaking
in Parliament uh at the health and
democracy conference on the 13th of
September of this year so this is a
month ago now already at EU at the EU
parliament in Strasburg and we will of
course share the link uh to the John
Campbell video uh but uh you know what
before we get to what the proposed
changes are let's jump to lawyer Cruz's
uh arguments about what these proposed
change lead to in which quote he says
the result is already predefined by one
sole Authority on the planet that one
sole Authority being the who if these if
these amendments are accepted uh which
at the moment it looks like they're
going to be uh we have six seven months
before uh the vote actually happens in
May of 2024 I believe the timeline
having been radically shortened that's
one of the messages uh in this speech is
that it the timeline went from 24 months
to 12 months and we're already a couple
months into that well if you cared about
uh not having this happen you would have
found the document in the
basement below the stairs that are
broken with the light off and the rats
and the uh pit of vipers and such yeah
your your reference to the The
Hitchhiker's Guide um yeah is uh well
taken yeah so at um at 9:28 in the video
um from John Campbell Cru the lawyer
says again at in September at the EU
Parliament meeting without open debate
without the possibility of having
different opinions different hypotheses
different methods there will be no
science there will be ultimately no
democracy and there will be no legal
Court proceedings and no justice he is
not speaking narrowly he is speaking as
broadly as he could possibly speak he is
speaking about no science no democracy
no legal Court proceedings no justice in
the
world if these amendments to this 2005
wh document are accepted now I would I
would advise people to think about that
claim and imagine what would have to be
true in this document for that claim not
to be a Preposterous exaggeration that's
the key yes further he says quote we
will not be asked we have not been
informed and there will be a process of
automatic enactment of the international
Health regulation this is about as
severe violation of the principle of
informed consent as possible this
principle doesn't exist only on the
individual level it exists also for
democracies as a whole the
self-determination of the people is one
of the founding principles of the United
Nations in article one of the founding
Charter of
1946 and finally one more short quote
from again this is the lawyer Philip
Cruz um speaking at the September 2223
EU Parliament meeting in Strasburg quote
it will be the wh that determines under
which legal status we have to live that
means that the power will not be anymore
in the hands of the people therefore
these regulations have to be stopt
immediately and we haven't walked
through yet what they may include but um
but we're going to do a bit of that here
yeah maybe we should talk a little bit
about that and then we can try to put it
in context you want to talk about the
provisions sure okay so here again and
you can show my screen now Zach uh this
is the who uh document the proposed
amendments to the international Health
regulations which were accepted ratified
I guess in 2005 which have been
submitted uh to be voted on in May I
believe of next year of
2024 uh so in this document does not
include everything that would be in the
in the resulting document it only
includes
um recommended deletions which are
strikethroughs and recommended additions
which are in bold and then um uh they
use ellipses they use um three dots uh
where they are skipping over uh parts of
the document that have not changed from
the original 2005 docum
so let's just start with uh article one
which is a place that uh John Campbell
also spend some time article one
definitions uh in which we are defining
what Health products are which uh later
on uh the who uh wants to Grant itself
the right to um Force these on nation
states and the people therein Health
Products include medicines vaccines
medical devices Diagnostics assistive
products cell and gene-based therapy and
other Health Technologies but not
limited to this
course
and although we don't have all of the
all of the text
here the standing
recommendation uh as originally
reflected in the 2005 document means
advice issued means non-binding advice
issued by The Who for specific ongoing
public health risks and the temporary
recommendation means non-binding advice
issued by The Who pursuant to article
etc etc but in the proposed amendment
the word non-binding is
deleted so the who would add specificity
around what Health Products include cell
and Gene based therapies vaccines Etc
and render their advice binding because
if it's not non-binding it's binding so
let me uh just fill that in in English
right with because they're obviously I
mean you know okay so they want to
delete a couple words non-binding that
means binding okay binding what binding
recommendation a binding recommendation
for what well there are two things on
the list that you ought to be paying
attention to one I mean you ought to pay
attention to them all but in
particular
vaccines and Gene
therapies what this document means is
that the who at its sole discretion
would like the abity AB ility to mandate
information be uploaded to your immune
system via vaccines and I mean true
vaccines or potentially the borrowing of
your cells to produce materials that
they were not built to produce as in the
MRNA vaccines or potentially included
within Gene editing they are talking
about a right to actually edit your
genome that would be in the hands of the
who through a
binding piece of advice a binding piece
of advice that means that your nation
would be required to facilitate your
genome to be edited or your immune
system to be updated even if there were
very good Arguments for not doing it and
frankly the only argument you should
need is that doesn't sound like a good
idea to me I don't want it y right
informed consent is acran as I pointed
out here as we pointed out months ago we
literally hung seven doctors for
violating this principle even though it
had not yet been codified it's that
clear yep and yet here the who wants the
power to force edits onto your genome or
to force updates into your immune system
this is beyond insane this could not
possibly be more dystopian and that's
just article one and that's just article
one article two which is about scope and
purpose uh I'm going to try to read it
in its original and then read it in its
uh updated form here what's on screen
you can show the screen here has both
inter interwoven um let's see if I can I
can do this the original from 2005 of
Article 2 scope and purpose of the who's
document reads the purpose and scope of
these regulations are to prevent protect
against control and provide a public
health response to the international
spread of disease in ways that are
commensurate with and restricted to
public health risk and which avoid
unnecessary interference with
International traffic and
trade the
recommended
changes of Article 2 scope and purpose
of the who document reads the purpose
and scope of these regulations are to
prevent protect against prepare control
and provide a public health response to
the international spread of diseases
including through Health Systems
Readiness and resilience in ways that
are commensurate with and restricted to
all risk with a potential to impact
public health and which avoid
unnecessary interference with
International traffic livelihoods human
rights and Equitable Access to Health
Products and Healthcare Technologies and
knowhow the big change there is we went
from public health risk to all risks
with a potential to impact Public Health
who will be the ones deciding whether or
not there's a potential to impact Public
Health well I imagine that would also be
the who wouldn't it who and I would
point out that the nature of Public
Health which we will get back to here at
some point uh is such that it's almost
inconceivable that
anything could be excluded right
everything has the potential to affect
Public Health anything that can affect
individual health can affect public
health and so the vagueness of this
definition the addition of the word
prepare which I'm not even sure why they
need it because they've got prevent in
there but anyway there's something
they're they're thinking something they
want the ability even when it's not
happening to say here's a mandate
because we are going to be prepared that
it will happen which I would tell you
should Echo you should now think of that
paragraph that these gain of function
Maniacs always used to justify their
work about the fact that increased human
contact with nature is meaning that the
likelihood of a zuntic disease leaping
out of Nature and causing a major human
pandemic is blah blah blah blah blah
therefore we must get ahead of this
thing by studying the X Y and Z in the
laboratory and enhancing the
pathogenicity of these things so that we
know what to do if they ever become
really pathogenic right that
paragraph that they use to you know to
Hoodwink people or to excuse themselves
or whatever it is that they do fits
exactly with this justification the
point is oh well we better maybe they
want to mandate some genetic edits now
for a pandemic that they that it isn't
but that they can talk themselves
into imagining could happen right
there's nothing here to prevent them
from doing that no there is there is
nothing here to prevent them from doing
that and I actually wanted to wanted to
point out that the very first paragraph
of this document uh which I just
scrolled by I didn't even show you guys
specifies U that what this do document
is is an article by
article um compilation of the proposed
amendments as authorized by the
submitting member states in the six
official languages without attribu of
the proposals to the member states
proposing them so we have a number of
changes to this document which has been
effectively again I don't know if
ratified is the right word but I'll use
it here by The Who in 2005 a number of
member states have
proposed you know everything from Bol to
Insidious changes and we can't see who
made what suggestions so we have no idea
what is actually moving behind the
scenes we know what we've got in front
of us but we don't know you know it
would be very useful to know if all of
the proposed changes of a type were
coming out of a particular country for
instance actually it's that's a great
point and I think this eluded me
entirely but the idea
that one of the the the Evergreen
portions of our failure globally
involves things driving things that are
supposed to be controlling it that
regulatory capture always looks like
this where the is doing the bidding of
the regulated and because everything is
labeled in some way it's misleading you
you can't tell that the FDA is uh
Downstream of fiser for example right um
and in this case the point is okay so
maybe some state is actually staging a
coup on other states through the who the
who is going to carve this thing out and
it sounds like the who is this Rogue
agency but the point is maybe you know
the Who belongs to somebody and this is
State a capturing the right right to
manipulate the citizens of State B via
the who right in the same way you know
we see with uh you know these Global
Financial organizations that uh
manipulate through through loans and
debt right and anonymity can be a uh
important indeed necessary Tool uh when
it comes to things like whistleblowing
uh but transparency in a document like
this would seem to be far more important
and even if you don't want to have it in
this document there should be a parallel
document wherein we the people can see
who it is has proposed the various
changes yeah it's really even hard to
construct a valid argument it's not like
it's it's easier to read I mean you
don't want to be bothered with those
things Brett um yes I do like
immediately um but but it really
honestly I struggle to find an argument
for anonymity in this context that isn't
laughable on its face I agree okay we're
not actually going to go through all
however many dozens of principles there
are but we are going to go briefly touch
on many of them and as you might expect
at the top of the top of the document
there the changes are bigger and grander
and more outstanding than than down
lower so article
three read
before
um the implementation of these
regulations shall be with full respect
for the dignity human rights and
fundamental freedoms of
persons
now it is being proposed that it shall
read the implementation of these
regulations shall be based on the
principles of equity inclusivity
coherence and in accordance with their
common but differentiated
responsibilities of the states parties
taking in consideration their social
economic development yada yada yada new
uh article 3.5 the state party shall
Implement these regulations on the basis
of once again Equity solidarity as well
as and in accordance with their common
differentiated responsibility respective
level of development State parties
Equity inclusivity coherence I don't
know how they Define that solidar
solidarity they use the word
solidarity so and we will see the very
last article that I will point us to
after we go through some number of the
rest of these we will see how their
focus on Equity will manifest um one of
the ways that they are actually
admitting that it will manifest uh
utterly extraordinary that and this was
again a point that John Campbell made uh
in his video that that anyone would look
at a document that says that the
implementation of Regulation shall be
with full respect for the dignity human
rights and fundamental freedoms of
persons and take out that
phrase and replace it with something
that is understood by all whether or not
they think it's awesome or the opposite
to be reflective of a new social
movement of an ideology that is it has
its own acronym right the University
equity and inclusion is a new thing
whereas dignity human rights and
fundamental freedoms of persons this is
ancient and this is necessary and who
would have us get rid of it inalienable
is the thing and yet they are alienating
it from us yes um so I see a couple
things there one I find it insane that
uh diversity equity and inclusion would
rear its ugly head in this place I guess
I can't be terribly surprised because
everything awful is going to be included
here but I also see the game theory and
it's terrifying right because if you
think about what it is let's go back to
the the days in which um those of us who
refused the shots were being witch
hunted um being accused of actually
Grandma killing and and all of this and
also cryptically in those shots because
obviously everyone's smart did because
of course
yeah whatever that witch hunting phase
was the underlying argument that these
people were making which is one that we
have to confront there's a component of
it that's true but the extrapolation is
dead wrong the component of it that's
true is that in an epidemiological
context the individual who opts out of
the shot if you're one individual and
you opt out of a shot that actually
works you get the benefit of everybody
else having taken the risk of the shot
and you don't take the risk and you get
the benefit of the immunity because the
population is immune so let's just take
that as a abstract
hypothetical using this argument they
can override informed consent directly
because the idea is you don't have the
right to opt out because other people
from disadvantage groups or whatever it
is opted in so we are going to force you
to take a risk that actually is not uh
matched with any benefit that you might
personally get because you're obligated
to roll the dice you're obligated to
play this game of roulette with the
others right and that is the most
obscene abuse of the idea of equity but
yet they're setting this up for it it's
it's clear that that is available to
them as an argument and that the
argument if you say no I don't want that
shot it's not good for me this is a
disease I'm not in danger of and that
shot is not nearly well enough
understand the point is guess what those
things are all irrelevant because
everybody else picked up the gun and
pointed at themselves and pulled the
trigger your turn yes right and I'm
sorry no
yes yes no yes
no kind of the era isn't it yeah yeah it
is it's very California yeah no yeah no
um okay Article Five is devoted to
surveillance uh which it always was I
guess um but even just the title of it
um so uh those of you who are
multitasking a multitasking is
impossible possible please be careful
and B um yes that's what I said pay
attention Okay surveillance what the
hell is surveillance doing in a document
about public health well you can see
where this is going can't
you so the following sentence remains
unchanged from the original 2005 one
each state party shall develop
strengthen and maintain as soon as
possible but no later than 5 Years From
the entry into force of these
regulations for that state party the
capacity to detect assess notify and
Report events in accordance with these
regulations as specified in Annex
one there's a lot here it's all about
surveillance some of which would be
warranted by a actually healthy and
functioning and not evil Public Health
apparatus wait wait wait depends what
you mean by surveillance if we're
talking about so they they are not using
it in the sense that we are
understanding it and they they are not
trying to use it in the sense of well
it's there it may not be in that under
that heading but it's there as we will
get to so uh just one because there's a
there's a lot we could be spending many
many hours on this document the one that
I chose to highlight here is their
new uh paragraph five of this uh this
was amendment five to strengthen the
central role of national health
authorities and management and
coordination with political
intersectoral interministerial and
multi-level authorities for timely and
coordinated surveillance and response in
accordance with the international health
risk indicated by the IH thereby
consolidating the central role of
national health authorities in
multi-level management and
coordination what could go wrong yeah
they're commandeering control of your
nation's Public Health apparatus so the
point is they they are decapitating your
the apparatus that is supposed to be
protecting uh the population and they
they are putting it under who control
yes no no Nation shall be Sovereign and
no human being shall be Sovereign this
is a direct attack on sovereignty in the
most profound ways your your
Constitution is subordinate to this
document which overrides it
yes um okay next is a ways down here
we've got article six notification
information
sharing consultation other reports let's
see what was the next again you I mean
everything that you're seeing that's in
bold or struck out are changes to the
proposed proposed changes to the
original document I believe Article 13
is the next place that I was going to
show you something yeah okay so Article
13 uh is broadly on public health
response um again the original uh which
is not proposed to be changed the
original first sentence reads each state
party shall develop strengthen and
maintain as soon as possible but no
later than 5 Years From the entry into
Force these regulations for that state
party the capacity to respond promptly
and effectively to public health risks
and public health emergencies of
international concern as set out in
Annex one okay uh again how is it the
public health risks and public health
emergencies are being
determined uh it is not uh any longer uh
entirely by the states it is it is by
The Who and here we have one of the
changes one of the many many changes to
Article 13 as uh described in the
document three the World Health
Organization shall in its allocation
plan for Health Products inter Alia
identify and prioritize the recipients
of Health Products including health
workers Frontline workers and vulnerable
populations and determine the required
quantity of healthcare products for
Effective distribution to the recipients
across States
parties the who would
decide how much of the Health Products
again which include cludes everything
from presumably actually uh important
and necessary medicines to Gene
therapies uh how much of each goes to
individual states and the rubrics that
they are using are now not human dignity
and individual freedom but things like
equity and
inclusion so you have a provision here
that actually speaks to this is going to
sound over rought but I think probably
as people are detecting the number of uh
sneaky and uh very important Provisions
here maybe maybe people are catching on
there's a kind of implication of a need
for medical communism here so you can
imagine a circumstance in which your
nation let's say it's stockpiles
materials that would be necessary in
case of a something yep and then the who
decides that those
materials uh are uh better applied
elsewhere in the globe and the fact that
you have paid for them and voted for
wise people who have collected them or
whatever doesn't matter because the who
decides that you know somebody else
deserves them more now of course there's
no mechanism for preventing the capture
of this apparatus so that those
materials might end up to you know those
who have corrupted the system that's
where they're likely to go but y um so
this this can happen in in both
directions they can mandate bad stuff
onto you they can take good stuff from
you and just think you know we have now
a history in which uh for example I
learned from Zev Zeno before he died
that uh the Netanyahu government
destroyed a warehouse of hydroxy
chloroquin before uh at the early stages
of the pandemic now imagine that the
idea was hydroxy
chloroquin uh was not desired to be
available for some reason and the idea
is oh well we can just simply transfer
it away to where it's more useful we can
decide that there's a danger of a
malaria outbreak somewhere and uh we can
arrange to have it all stockpiled
somewhere that you can't get access to
it the ability of Provisions like this
to rearrange the materials of the world
so that you just simply can't defend
yourself is is utterly profound yeah I
don't
know I don't have any idea of what the
implications are for a nation state that
creates the goods themselves are are
they to be required to share them under
the Equitable Equitable rules decided by
The Who or are they to be allowed
allowed uh to keep what they make for
their own citizens I don't know let's
put it this way the Theo of the
authoritarians who are arranging to re
to reorganize the the rights that we
have have according to their new rules
what they are doing is they are hoarding
discretion they are carving out
Provisions that allow them to dictate
anything at any moment and the basic
point is they would like every Liberty
and they would like you to have none and
what they will do is they will then give
you as a privilege what was once your
right so you won't detect that this is
happening Life Will Go On like normal
until they need something and then the
point is oh well but you sign up for
this who treaty no I didn't yes you did
you did because your nation your nation
did agreed to it really they did people
yeah sorry why didn't I hear about it
and the answer is you didn't hear about
it because it was too boring for anybody
to report and it was designed to be too
boring for anybody to report and so you
just didn't know but yeah you did sign
up for this this is actually your
representativ let this happen and in
terms of day-to-day life you you said it
but um it will be invisible to people
until it's not but at that point it will
be too late precisely because the change
the change will not register because
what is now your right will by accepting
if if if these changes are accepted in
May of
2024 um by the nation states who would
vote on them uh then what are currently
your rights have become privileges uh
which are granted um by the beneficence
of The Who as opposed to which are yours
because you have uh autonomy as a free
human
being um I'm speechless at some level
yeah if this document doesn't leave you
speechless you haven't you haven't read
it carefully enough for these proposed
changes to the document go ahead well I
was going to say um I was just going to
go to the next one article 18 uh which
actually it's not the changes that
surprised me it's worth noting how many
things the who already had
uh in the original 2005 docum how much
sovereignty we gave up without ever
knowing it Happ exactly we can we go
there next and then so Artic article 18
recommendations with respect to persons
baggage cargo containers conveyances
goods and postal Parcels uh will just
stick to one which is recommendations
issued by The Who to States parties with
respect to persons and it's almost
identical list um to the one to number
two which is baggage cargo containers
conveyances goods and postal Parcels um
but with a to persons recommendations
may include the following no specific
Health measures are advised obviously it
seems a strange thing to have to mention
review travel history and affected
history and affected areas review proof
of medical examination and any
laboratory analysis review medical
examinations review proof of vaccination
or other
prophylaxis require vaccination or other
prophylaxis Place suspect persons under
Public Health observation Implement
quarantine or other health measures for
suspect persons implement isol ation and
treatment were necessary of affected
persons Implement tracing of contacts of
suspect or affected persons refuse entry
of suspect and affected persons refuse
entry of unaffected persons to affected
areas and Implement exit screening Andor
restrictions on persons from affected
areas and we've experienced some of
these right um you know we we have we
have traveled in places where we have
been
required actually I'm not
sure no at at at National boundaries as
well but more actually at a at a at a
military checkpoint in the Amazon where
we were required to show proof of yellow
fever vaccine vaccination um within the
nation state of of Ecuador
um and given what we at least understood
then about uh the prevalence of yellow
fever and the safety and efficacy of the
yellow fever vaccine and the uh and what
I am still certain of uh the direness of
the disease that is yellow fever uh that
seemed uh that seemed legitimate but
that actually was outside of the purview
of what this is anyway because that
wasn't a state border um a nation state
border I wanted to
just as an
exercise get people to start thinking
people who write
constitutions have to think very
carefully about how that document
function in a world that they cannot
know because it hasn't happened yet this
this document no people who write a good
Constitution the founders and you know
our Founders screwed some stuff up they
put priorities on some things that were
looming large in their mind that were
less of an issue in the future and
really really well they did it much
better than one would imagine they they
uh they beat the odds substantially so
I'm not giving them any hard time I'm
just saying it's inherent that you will
have uh a Mis prioritization just based
on where you are in history
mhm
the exercise involves saying okay what
scenario can I imagine and what would it
do with this provision this right I'm
carving out how will that thing go wrong
in an environment that I can't know
anything about and we have to do that
with a document like this we have to say
well what you know what could fall under
this that you would not see coming and I
just want to point point something out
good you have certainly heard rhetoric
about gun violence being a public health
matter and we all understand the
argument right that's not a clever turn
of phrase that is an argument to exert a
kind of control that unhooks the second
amendment in the US the idea that there
is a priority that requires a central
coordination in which your normal rights
would not apply now so far the second
amendment has effectively held but in
this document we are talking about
giving or the modifications of this
document we're talking about giving the
who sweeping powers to define a public
health
emergency there is nothing that I see
that prevents them from saying oh yes
gun violence is a public health
emergency and I would also point out
that if you think about what happened at
the beginning of the pandemic as the uh
George Floyd riots happened right we
there was a debate everybody will
remember it you've got people gathering
at a moment where you are told Gathering
is immoral and the response that came
back was that racism was the real Public
Health
Emergency Gathering was immoral under
protest if what you were protesting was
lockdown right Gathering was moral if
what you were protesting was racism and
racism was actually the true public
health emergency and there we have it
again right race guns and race racism
are both Public Health potentially
Public Health emergencies we've already
been told so what couldn't possibly fall
under this purview and what happens if
you've got somebody over in who
headquarters thinking well uh Public
Health Emergency oh guns uh racism um
can and they have the right to
redistribute whatever they want on the
basis of the greater good for public
health and Equity can they you know
let's say that the idea is that
uh there is a war in which everybody has
been caused to wave the right flag and
they need some guns and we really don't
like the population having guns because
there's a public health emergency
involving them can they transfer guns to
a foreign Battlefield from your gun safe
on the basis that your government gave
away its right to object to the who
deciding what is and what isn't a public
health emergency and in what way things
might be redistributed sounds
Preposterous to me on the other hand the
number of things that are actually real
facts today that I would have said 5
years ago sound utterly preposterous is
too many to count y so and if you signed
on uh to uh this document you signed on
to to the who being able to
decide what marks the equitable
distribution of something yet
unspecified right so
anyway I I guess the other place to
realize this I I keep trying to tell
people when somebody invokes terrorism
you hear a linguistic turn of phrase you
might hear a claim that you say is
overblown or isn't you don't understand
that they are invoking a huge body of
law that you have never seen the idea
that someone if they say you know Mal
information terrorism that sounds like
they've gone stupid and they're saying
silly things no they're actually
defining people as not entitled to
constitutional rights rights because of
some definition about information that's
true but causes you to distrust your
government you're now a terrorist right
what they are saying is actually we now
have the right to do anything to you
based on our sole judgment that you fall
in this category that we made up right
that's what's going on the game is they
create perfect discretion for themselves
and they rob you of rights that you are
sure you have and couldn't be relieved
from you if without your notice you're
wrong they're doing it in documents we
don't know who we know the who but we
don't know who is actually behind this
right and we don't know what their
objective is so we're always behind in
terms of figuring out what what the game
is but nonetheless if you just simply
extrapolate from what they are saying
this is a direct hit on the sovereignty
of whatever Nation you live in it is a
direct hit on your individual right to
refuse things like medical uh treatment
ments and technologies that you don't
want a right that you know we had a
hanging offense and now the point is
that right is going to be quietly
relieved from you and the reason that
you're not going to know is that this is
being done in such a boring process that
nobody even people who would in
principle be interested in talking about
it aren't going to because it's just too
much yeah
so there
are there are a number of ways that this
is terrifying honestly um article 23 the
next one I wanted to mention is about
health measures on arrival and departure
and so this is about um what they can
require of you and about showing your
papers and uh you know papers please
show your papers
papers
um has a is is a is a Trope which
everyone recognizes and even even even
though everyone recognizes that now and
everyone has always recognized that uh
we know that we're going to have to
share our passport when we cross
international borders and uh we have
known as anyone will have uh if they
crossed International borders to
particular places or from particular
places that we would also have to show
that yellow um vaccine card right
demonstrating that we had been
vaccinated against a few things that
were required to go into a few
countries which didn't strike me until
recently as obviously problematic mhm it
does
now um but it's not only
because the people who are asking us to
show our papers aren't trustworthy which
they have completely demonstrated that
they're not uh in terms of when they
will use their Authority for good or ill
but also what has been clear forever
about which Co put into Stark relief
the the wouldbe Health Products again
which includes everything from medicines
and vaccines to Gene therapies and
cellular therapies um are built on a
system a medical system that does not
understand what humans are or what
evolution is or what it would mean to
actually diagnose and treat to cure as
opposed to to keep you a patient for
life so given these two sets of perverse
incentives uh well the the first is a
potentially perverse incentive the
people who are getting to decide whether
or not you have to show your papers uh
may have an interest in you showing your
papers when it's really about their
benefit and not yours uh but then the
fact that the medical system is so
broken that there is no reason that we
should assume that they actually know
what they're
doing the papers and then the products
that uh we would be asked to be forced
to reveal that we have taken on the
papers that we have to to show are are
not a legitimate ask they're just
not well I wanted to come back to this
at the end and maybe we will again but I
think um as true as what you said is and
as profound as it is
it's the truth is so much
more extreme if you use coid to diagnose
the quality of the evaluation
inside the global Public Health
apparatus how much did these people get
right right yeah the answer is even let
we could imagine a world in which the
who had done a great job had really
reduced the amount of death and
suffering on Earth had reduced the
spread of the virus you can imagine a
world in which you had a well
functioning global Public Health
apparatus if you handed that thing this
document it would still be an
unmitigated disaster for sovereignty and
individual rights yes the idea of
handing this document to an apparatus
that has just proven it doesn't either
doesn't give a about people
suffering and dying or is incapable of
protecting them even if it did I mean
why not both uh you know I think I think
it doesn't have the capacity because we
can see everyone can now see like most
doctors don't know what they're
doing they they don't understand
diagnosis they don't understand what
disease is they don't understand that
actually the health of the body
pre-exposure to the disease is going to
affect how sick you
get it
is simply
Unthinkable that you would take take an
entity that had that had failed as badly
as the who failed and award them any
more Powers this makes no sense the
quite the opposite would be the right
reaction what what capacity does this
organization have that we should remove
from it in light of the fact that it
appears to be incompetent or
Worse right and so there is something
about the contrast between what we just
lived through which tells us everything
you need to know about what these people
do with
power and the idea that we are going to
hand them you
know levels of power that are until now
Unthinkable we are talking about global
power over the citizens of the world
this organization which has served us so
poorly so I I
again I like you I don't know what to
think about
vaccine cards and Nations requiring you
to take these things in order to go to X
Y and Z police place at least I know I
have the right to decide not to go there
right right I do retain the right not to
take a yellow fever vaccination if I
deem that dangerous
but you're right the the very fact that
we allowed this it's not that there's no
way it could work that would make sense
and protect your rights but the idea
that we just simply accepted it like so
many things right I accepted um
vaccination we accepted vaccination for
our kids and it's not that there's
anything wrong with the idea not Co
right yeah but we accepted it in a
general sense before we understood the
problem of adant and the role they were
playing in these Corner cutting vaccine
Technologies and you know it's a warning
we we we should have scrutinized this
stuff a long time ago and we didn't in
part because they did such a good job of
portraying people who did scrutinize
them as uh morally defective
demons that's
right so that that mostly covers what I
wanted to say about article 23 Health
measures on arrival and departure but uh
there are a couple of interesting things
here
uh doc including documents containing
information for a lab test uh
so things that you might be asked to
show upon arriving or departing from
some sovereign state um but have
Sovereign anymore if the who is
declaring what it can tell the sovereign
state to require of people visiting
including documents containing
information for a lab test in digital or
physical format including documents
containing information on a Laboratory
test for a pathogen and or information
on vaccination against a disease
including those provide the request of
the state party in a digital or
electronic form new this is a new
paragraph uh in the proposed revisions
documents containing information
concerning Travelers destination should
preferably be produced in digital form
with paper form as a residual
option so I include that if I can have
my screen back here I just want to
scroll through and not make people dizzy
um they are
talking about requiring all sorts of
things here you can show my screen again
here this is article 35 several down
Health documents may be produced in
digital or paper form so they want your
arri your the documents saying where
you're going to preferably be in digital
form why do they why why why do they
care particularly about that Health
documents may be produced in digital or
paper form is that just a nod to the
fact that um generally if you're
traveling where you're going exists in
electronic form and so if you can you
should show it in electronic form and in
many parts of the world your health
documents don't exist in the paper or
digital form or is this them going okay
we understand this can't happen yet but
really we want everything digital we
want to move everything digital
everything has to be electronic which
you know again sounds easier it sounds
traceable it sounds like you end up with
a common place where everything
lives and paper makes more sense under a
lot of circumstances and is preferable
for the human
being but not for The Entity who would
track that human being well there are a
couple things in this document I think
you're going to bring some of them up
here shortly there are a couple things
in this document that appear to work in
the direction of people's rights and I
must tell you given what's in this
document I don't trust it for a second
my guess is these things will be
potentially used to get people to relax
and then they will quietly be changed in
the next iteration or whatever it is but
my inter interpretation of the desire
for electronic form obviously any person
can recognize it's easier that there's a
lot of advantage in the electronic just
at a practical level um you know if it's
a card in your electronic wallet you're
not going to lose it in the way that you
might lose an actual
card but my expectation is that so many
of these mechanisms of control come down
to things that they can revoke mhm you
can imagine if you need documents that
demonstrate your status relative to
their mandate in order to cross borders
that they can imprison You by you know
if they can close your bank account
because you say things that they decide
are uh
intolerable can they freeze you in place
right can they effectively lock you
personally down by uh invalidating your
electronic certificate it's very you you
may be can't lose the card in your
electronic wallet but they could right
and but they can't lose the physical
card in your physical wallet these
people are so hellbent on their right to
extrapolate from simplistic conclusions
about who is good and who is bad and who
is putting the world in Jeopardy that
they feel entitled to do it look hey if
you are the son of a spreading
information that is causing the world to
be in Jeopardy of of pathogen
X then we obviously have the right to do
anything to stop you because you're
Typhoid Mary so you know what does that
include well it includes messing with
you it includes interfering with your
ability to earn it includes interfering
with your ability to keep your money
safe to spend it as you would like to
move from one place to another the point
is once they decide that because you are
an unacceptable person they have any
right that they wish in order to control
you then we have to start getting
imaginative about all of the ways in
which they might control us because
really this is our only hope for
retaining our individual sovereignty yep
and as you alluded to uh there are a
couple of bones that we've been thrown
in this document uh here we have one in
article 36 certificates of vaccination
or other
prophylaxis um other types of proofs and
certificates may be used by parties to
attest the holder status as having a
decreased risk of being the disease
carrier particularly where a vaccine or
prophylaxis has not yet been made
available for a disease in respect of
which a public health emergency of
international concern has been declared
such proofs may include test
certificates and Recovery certificates
recovery certificates I read that and
thought there's one little bone right
there was a lot there was a lot sort of
mid pandemic about how just because
you've had Co doesn't mean you can't you
don't need to show proof of vaccination
in order to get into you know fill in
the venue of your choice here and um
while Co does seem to be remarkably
Adept at changing out from under us and
eluding both natural immunity and
vaccine induced immunity to the degree
that it exists uh natural immunity has
always been the best form of immunity uh
to disease and here we are recovery
certificates thank you I guess well so
here's the problem uh and let's just be
straightforward about this I am engaging
in an exercise in which I am allowing my
imagination to spot how these things
will be turned against us because
obviously this the alteration to this
document is hostile to our interests as
individuals right so in that vein I do
not believe it is paranoid to think how
might this what appears to be a
concession to uh to natural immunity be
a weapon and here's what I'm
wondering
given all of the other Provisions that
we've talked about their ability to
redistribute tests and materials and
Health Products Health Products as they
wish and given
that there's no way that the Suns of
who are going to mandate that
they are allowed to edit our genes or
Force updates on our immune system
there's no way those people are going to
accept the same for themselves and so by
creating this if I can't get a test that
says I've recovered from pathogen X but
they can get a test that says they've
recovered from pathogen X and therefore
they are excluded from their mandate but
I am not right they win so uh whereas
the first time that you read that
provision to me I thought yeah okay
they'll pull it later now I wonder if
it's not part of a shell game where the
idea is they actually want a a way out
because they know they can keep me from
accessing it and they can use it so that
the explanation for why they never got
their so-called vaccine well they
recovered from the disease right it's
right there in the
document
yeah okay two
more article 43 additional Health
measures uh from the original these
regulations these regulations shall not
preclude States parties from
implementing Health measures in
accordance with their relevant national
law and obligations under international
law in response to specific Public
Health risks or public health
emergencies of international
concern I'm going to read the original
that I've got highlighted here and then
read the
modifications such measures shall not be
more restrictive of international
traffic and not more invasive or
intrusive to persons than reasonably
available Alternatives that
attain the no sorry it's tough okay I'm
going to try to read the original again
such measures shall not be more
restrictive of international traffic and
not more invasive or intrusive to
persons than reasonably available
Alternatives that would
achieve
attain no no I think it's I think attain
it's an error it's an error attain
should be in bold yeah right okay so I'm
sorry guys I'm gonna try again um such
measures shall not be more restrictive
of international traffic and not more
invasive or intrusive to persons than
reasonably available Alternatives that
would achieve the appropriate level of
Health protection achieve the
appropriate level of Health protection
as it read in the original 2005 document
proposed
amendments such measures shall be based
on regular risk assessments provide a
proportionate response to the specific
public health risks be reviewed on a
regular basis and shall not be more
restrictive of international traffic and
not more invasive or intrusive to
persons than reasonably available
Alternatives that would attain the
highest achievable level of Health
protection ouch yeah so so I don't know
what you see there but I see lots of
games that they played during coid for
which they are now stacking the deck to
make those games more effective and um
that would achieve the appropriate level
of Health protection appropriates also
gameable right it's subjective but would
attain the highest achievable level oh
yes I know you've tried but you haven't
gone as high as you can and we are here
to tell you what the highest achievable
level is and to enforce that well
I I take it as a little bit more
specific if the point is appropriate
protection could be achieved by a great
many
approaches highest is by definition one
and in a world where they can game the
statistics and the the academic
Publications to make things look highly
efficacious through tricks like uh the
one that uh Martin Neil and Norman
Fenton pointed to yeah then the point is
well they all they have to do is make
some claim that they can point to that
this is the most effective way to deal
with pathogen X and then the point is
well it doesn't really matter what else
you got going because it ain't the
highest no we got we got to get to the
highest so they can shove any
alternative off the map by just simply
setting a thing that says only the
highest and then they can game that one
which of course is also once again not
how Evolution works not how pathogens
work right you know no thing in in a in
an evolving system is going to be now
and forever be the most effective
treatment against a pathogen that will
evolve out from under your treatment
right it it is impossible right and so
they are imagining they they are trying
to implement a static set of top- down
authoritarian rules in a world which
everyone knows is neither is not static
what's more so they've set a remedies
come in a variety of whatevers but
there's a high EST it belongs to us and
you'll take it because you don't have
anything that's the highest do you okay
and then the other thing that they do is
they say regular risk assessments well
what the hell did they do with risk
assessment in this pandemic yeah they
completely gamed it to the point that
people died in large numbers from their
protocols which they then counted as
deaths that followed from the disease
rather than from their reaction to it
which then caused the disease to look a
great deal more deadly than it actually
was so the point is what they're carving
out is hey we would like to define a set
of Standards the only standards we will
accept are the ones that we are expert
at gaming that we have completely rigged
to the point that there is nothing you
could possibly come up with that would
deviate our course we want to be able to
rationalize a policy on the basis of a
risk assessment that will be nonsense
and the uh set of Remedies which will be
narrowed to One MH that's that's what
that paragraph says and you know that
paragraph alone is a direct hit on your
medical sovereignty and informed consent
and it's you know one of dozens here
that are being altered in dramatic and
dire ways yes indeed it
is okay one more
uh article 48 terms of reference and
composition unchanged from the original
the director General shall establish an
emergency committee that at the request
of the director General shall provide
its views on a whether an event
constitutes a public health emergency of
international concern B the termination
of a public health emergency of
international concern and C the proposed
issuance modification extension or
termination of temporary
recommendations okay who shall make up
the emergency committee do you think
again unchanged from the original 2005
document the director General shall
select the members of to the emergency
committee on the basis of the expertise
and experience required for any
particular session and with due regards
to the principles of Equitable
geographic
representation propos
modifications the director General shall
select the members of the emergency
committee on the basis of the expertise
and experience required for any
particular session and with due regard
to the principles of Equitable age
gender and geographical representation
and gender balance and require training
in these regulations before
participation
in an
emergency they need to form a
committee that is gender
balanced because that's what the world
looks like because having a
committee that thinks it's in the It's a
Small World ride at
Disneyland is more important than
actually getting the best possible
people together in a room to figure out
what is going on
on maybe all the best people to figure
out a particular uh a particular health
risk that is happening maybe because
it's actually affecting mostly women or
all
women maybe it's mostly men either way
the idea that an equitable age and
gender distribution and then specifying
gender balance is part of
this they just revealed even more of
their
cards this is unbelievable it's an
unthinkable priority literally you you
the idea that you are going to
prioritize the rights to be in the room
over the rights of planet Earth to get
the best possible expertise that it
could possibly gather is it's batshit
crazy and I don't even know what they
got hiding over an age space like are
they going to ask 5-year-olds like it's
one thing to point to you know the US
and the politicians be like for you
freak sake Boomers Move Along right but
it's quite another thing to say
Equitable age from what to what what
what are your Max and Men on that
so again hoarding discretion is what
they're doing right so imagine that
you're going to put a bunch of
parameters do you remember when George
Bridges created a committee to do his
bidding a committee president Evergreen
president Bridges and he handpicked the
members of a committee that then turned
the college upside down on on on his
onck the members of a committee who had
the most grievances against everyone
right but imagine that you had a list of
characteristics that sounded very Noble
that was going to dictate who might be
on this committee and then somebody
proposes somebody inconvenient for the
committee and it's like well the problem
is we have too many people in this age
demographic or too many people who are
are you know between 5'6 and 5'9 and
whatever it is and this is kind of
directly relevant but not exactly on on
on point here I had this happen when I
when I was chairing the provos committee
at evering some years before we had
someone come in from HR and
say but you don't have any applicants
from the South Pacific I kid you not the
South Pacific and I went like
huh that's amazing that that's the group
that we now have to care about the
most it was South Pacific Islanders and
then we then had to put ads out in IR
relevant places like unbelievable right
but the point is it's just like look if
you need a bespoke obstacle at a moment
because your attempt to create a
committee that will rubber stamp
whatever garbage you're putting together
then the point is you want a long list
of things to which you might appeal at
the at the relevant moment and that's
that's what they're doing and and um it
just doesn't stop the number doesn't
stop I mean I'm going to stop now
because that's well so you're done
you're done with Provisions I'm done
with articles and Provisions and I mean
there it goes on and on and on I'm stop
now a whole level of the compliance
committee shall be authorized okay
there's a whole level of this document
that we're not getting to which involves
the who's right to control what we talk
about okay so the the I'll make this
point
simply a lot of what this document means
can be understood just simply by
rerunning the co pandemic under these
new Provisions now of course Goliath
whatever he is composed of and whatever
his game really is
Goliath is livid that his narrative
collapsed under the pressure of people
who weren't supposed to be listened to
he had
he had accumulated he had hoarded tools
with which to ruin the reputation of
anybody who had expertise who stood up
anybody like you and me who managed to
figure out how to talk about these
issues in real time to simplify them so
that people could understand what was
being said right he knew that he owned
all the properties needed to ruin us and
it didn't work and what happened is his
narrative completely collapsed and I
will point out we have currently
something like a 2% acceptance rate of
the new boo ERS for Co two I believe so
and fizer's stock price is in collapse
okay so he doesn't want to live through
that again maybe they'll sacrifice fizer
frankly maybe they've even shorted fizer
and they're going to you they're going
to allow fizer to uh capsize and we're
all going to imagine that the wicked
witch is dead but the wicked witch is
just the other Farmers now so who knows
but we beat their narrative with
basically what I would argue our grass
Roots institutions that sprung up to
discuss the failures of the established
institutions that's what happened it
happened in places it shouldn't have
happened it happened on podcasts which
are not the appropriate place to be
discussing uh science at this level but
nonetheless it had to be done somewhere
so speak easys happened they were on
podcasts it allowed discussion of the
relevant things and Goliath is pissed so
Goliath has arranged that next time the
public health emergency will allow The
Who to dictate what is discussible and
what isn't and by whom and so there are
a lot of direct attacks on our
sovereignty as um individuals capable of
having a conversation about what our
interest might be and our informed
consent so I would just ask people to
pay attention to that whole other line
of attack because if you think about the
who being in a position uh to Define
people as unforgivably
malinformed um because the public health
demands it and uh you know uh to have
the you know the
uh what would it be to have their I
don't know their right to think squeezed
right out of them um then this is this
is the document and this is this is and
it's actually two documents there are
two different there's a treaty level
thing and a um a a much more structural
level thing but you don't mean that
there that we have only been looking at
one of the two documents you're talking
about it it's it's working at two levels
it it is a pair of uh sets of Provisions
that function differently under who
rules so anyway let's leave it at that
you can go and you can look at uh the
John Campbell video it covers this um
but we have a whole an attack across the
entirety of the places where we actually
succeeded under coid and it is going to
if we don't derail it it is going to be
a disaster going forward they will
Define emergencies that may not be
emergencies or they will capitalize on
emergencies that are emergencies and we
will discover what all of the stuff is
for um then and I guess the final thing
I would say
is the real Public Health
Emergency is this treaty change right
this is a public health emergency people
are going to die as a result of the
powers that these people are carving out
for themselves they have their own
objectives we don't know what they are
but from the point of view of the public
health this document is the public
health emergency and we should treat it
as such yes
indeed well
um should we stop there and go to our
Q&A or do you have some you want to
touch a few more things a couple more
things that we should talk about all
right one in thinking about a great many
issues in the last week I came up with
something that I thought was useful and
people will find it irresistible to map
it onto the current crisis
crisis I would be lying if I didn't
think it did map on to the current
crisis but it is much more General and
much more useful because it is not
specifically about the current crisis so
Zach would you show my tweet of
this okay so I
said the formula colon a complex story
suddenly becomes the irresistible focus
of public attention most people have no
background knowledge about the relevant
influences technical aspects or hidden
stakeholders
the story has an intuitive human element
a moral Dimension that forces everyone
to react complexity is artificially
reduced to a binary Choice those who
explore extra Dimensions notice
inconsistencies or apply historical
lessons are publicly punished for an
inferred moral defect those who have
fallen for the false dichotomy pile on
intimidating and isolating those who
reject the
simplification now I think that this is
actually a um a pretty good map of their
playbook that there are forces that want
us to do things they are incapable of
manipulating us individually so what
they do is they get us to do their
bidding for them right we are swept into
things uh for reasons that we think we
understand and we do not understand what
else is in play I just want to I do want
to point out one thing about the um the
barbaric Hamas attacks and the way that
they fit with this and I'm a little
hesitant to do it because I don't really
want to pollute the observation about
this pattern with the particulars of any
story but one thing that I think
is causing people not to think carefully
in the current crisis is that there is
one layer of it that is actually
unusually
perfectly clear right there is no
ambiguity whatsoever about the evil of
Hamas Hamas made certain that we would
understand that they bent over backwards
to make sure that we saw it with our own
eyes and they were so over the top in
their barbarity that any person who
doesn't get it any person who is not
perfectly horrified at the idea of the
way some of the victims died is just
simply an incomplete person there's no
way you could understand what took place
at the hands of Hamas there's no Nuance
there none they made sure of it m and on
the other hand the victims were
overwhelmingly just citizens right they
it wasn't even there was no parsing it
wasn't even that they went after men
right these were just citizens men women
children
innocent people going about their lives
who came into contact with absolute
monsters and it is that Simplicity that
layer that has no need for nuance there
is no Nuance anybody who's arguing for
nuance at that layer is
just I mean I don't even know how to
describe the failure of anybody who is
attempting to apply Nuance to that layer
but my point is the human mind is not
good at dealing with a situation in
which there is a layer that is so black
and
white and then seeing the layers in
which there is something else whatever
it is and I am watching with horror yes
people react to the one layer that is so
clear yes and because of that they are
losing their capacity to think about
layers that are not perfectly clear and
it is frightening frankly it is
frightening I I have the sense that um
whatever we learned about Mass formation
I don't think we fully get it yet yeah
different people are bewildered by
different crises some people get one
crisis and they miss the next I'm not
quite sure how it all fits together but
the number of people who because there
is one Crystal Clear layer cannot figure
out that the other layers are not
something to skip over that they all
have to be dealt
with can I actually read um something
about about this moment that is relevant
to what you were talking about but you
can show my screen here Zack um what I
posted on Natural Selections today it's
a short short piece that I call it kind
of winning the shape of this moment in
time an illusion to um the Pink Floyd
lyrics that we talked about um on on the
last on the last episode of Darkhorse uh
and I'm not g to I'm not going to read
the beginning
um we are being played yes there will
always be conflict
yes resources are finite and far too
many people have far too few of them yes
people will come to different
conclusions about what to do based on
what their priorities are who they know
what they are being told what lives they
themselves have lived but there are
forces that profit by keeping us
confused weary and each other's throats
those forces are profiting
now so of the chaos and hysteria that is
Downstream with the barbaric attacks by
Hamas on Israeli C civilians on October
7th was predictable people in both camps
are willing to conflate civilians with a
terrorist organizations or governments
that claim to represent them Israelis
are not their government only one
Israeli is Benjamin
Netanyahu Palestinians are not Hamas a
large fraction of people in Gaza are
children but while condemning the rape
murder and kidnapping a festival goers
should have been easy and obvious for
everyone it was not many instead are
celebrating the brutality of
Hamas my friend Holly has pointed out
that we got here in part by ignoring far
too many warning signs welcome to the
world of intersectionality she writes
anyone with any identity characteristics
that rank high on the oppression scale
is due respect trust difference and
entitled to have their feelings catered
to to the fullest extent possible the
forces that profit from our Exquisite
rage only need convince us that having
dark skin or being Palestinian for
instance are the most deserving identity
characteristics add the divisive
ideology of the moment and VOA bickering
on a scaled end
civilization that postmodern inflected
identity politics would spill off campus
in explosive and awful way as was
predicted in 2018 testimony before
Congress by you and I encourage people
to click on that and watch that
testimony it's 15 minutes long it's
extraordinary this was not long after he
and I were rejected you and I rejected
from our own campus for objecting to
racism that was passing itself off as
the opposite now finally the wealthy
donors that so heavily fund our Elite
institutions have woken up and are
beginning to pull their funds and now
finally the institutions are beginning
to
listen what the left has become in
recent years is a vengeful hateful
ideology that prioritizes immutable
characteristics and would have its way
through authoritarian means black lives
matter is racist at its core but many
liberals were fooled by the name it gave
to itself the footnote there is I was
too at first some of those liberals
erected don't hurt me walls to protect
themselves others Spilled Out onto the
streets there is some truth to Horseshoe
Theory Yasmin Muhammad is a prominent
human rights campaigner who at 19 was
married off to a member of al-Qaeda by
her mother she had an interview
published this week which I hope has
read
in it she reports that her father now
dead was from Gaza Gaza was his homeland
he was also a loving man A Generous man
and his heart broke for the inability of
the region to find peace he blamed Hamas
for this
failure Muhammad's mother in stark
contrast is filled with hatred for Jews
but also for apostates when Yasmin left
Islam her mother told her that she would
have Yasmin
killed the anti-Semitism of sheltered
white Western liberals does not have the
same Origins as the anti-Semitism of
yasmin's of yasman Muhammad's mother but
hatred finds common ground and from
there it
grows but all is not lost and I go on
not too much
longer it all fits together in ways that
we have not fully figured out but um
resisting the wouldbe tyranny of the
who uh is another place
where reading the abstract and saying
I'm sure it'll be fine is not going to
be
sufficient reading not even reading the
abstract just taking one
of I said this to you the other day it's
like we have been tricked into believing
that life is a multiple choice test and
that we are being constantly handed
multiple choice
answers to issues and questions as they
arise and when those of us who were
never interested in multiple Choice
tests because we knew it didn't reflect
reality it could not reflect any kind of
complexity say not a not b not c not d
none of those but not any of what you
have offered is not sufficient I want to
figure out what
yes then we get back to what you were
saying we are engaging in some sort of
awful awful behavior that cannot be that
can no one will stand for it because how
could we not stick to the Scantron how
could we not just take the multiple
choice test as it's
offered so I want to speak to the what I
think is the the upshot of what you're
saying um there is a pattern of History
it is Relentless there is the modern
version of that pattern which is new in
some ways and familiar in
others it seems obvious to me
that the proper response that is to say
the only response that actually in my
opinion leaves human beings on a
tolerably intact Planet 500 years from
now is going to
involve making deeply counterintuitive
moves to the extent that there are
answers it involves not becoming
reflexive and doing what it is that
seems obvious that you must do in the
moment which doesn't mean that reflex is
never the right thing but it means means
as you point out that our reflexes are
being
utilized to control us and that has put
me in yes what I regard as a very
unpleasant position trying to make
certain points that I believe are vital
in this
context um in other words I'm trying to
not see the clarity of that very clear
layer and be forced to embrace Embrace a
set of things that are
unclear because I want to Proclaim just
how um just how on the right side I am
right so there is some set of things
that we have to address complexities
that are real that have nothing to do
with the innocence of the victims or the
monstrousness of the villains right they
really don't but they do have to do with
our Collective well-being they have to
do with the long-term well-being of
Israel and frankly Palestine both of
those things are tied up in this and we
have to behave counterintuitively which
is
um
so desperately unpleasant to attempt
because what happens as I described in
my formula for how this game works
people who are good people who do not
know that they are participating in it
are trying to turn up the heat so hot
that you are forced to bail out into the
established camp
and what that means is that if you try
this you try not to be forced then what
you end up with is
accusations that you are falling flat
with respect to the morally unambiguous
stuff right you are you're the deepest
parts of your character are called into
question and it doesn't matter that you
know that this is a bad rap point is
even just seeing yourself portrayed that
way is so unpleasant
that that it works that people jump
and um I
would I don't know what I'm asking
people to do but just think about
whether or not because there's a part of
your mind that sees something very very
clear in front of you and you want
everybody else to see it too whether or
not you are actually reducing the
dimensionality of a puzzle that
the bottom level perfectly clear at
other
levels uh strange and everything is
writing on it and we you know there is
no in in a
circumstance where there is the world
has so much writing on what happens um a
rush to any conclusion is a mistake and
it is it is the desire not to leave a
conversation in which we are you know
questioning the innocence of the victims
that is causing people to say no
actually this is the moment to rush and
that is I swear to you it's a mistake
it's a terrible terrible mistake for the
world there there are forces out there
that um there are forces out there
frankly that like War for economic
reasons right are you certain they're
not in play here really how could you be
how how could anyone be um so we we have
to we have to we have to engage this
better and uh it's
significant
um can we end on what normally would be
um really a very dark note but I think
in this context is actually a uh a
lighter note I have no idea where we're
going but uh can you want you want to
play that uh video from the uh uh what
is it the the Democratic Party of Canada
National Democratic Party of Canada yeah
all right so uh take a listen a reminder
that we will enfor
gender parity at the mics and Adrien
explained the process with the yellow
card as well so please remember to give
space to those who face systemic
barriers and discrimination including
women black indigenous and racialized
folk in particular people living with
disabilities and 2s
lgbtqia plus
folk our convention has special speaker
priority for gender Equity if you ident
Iden ify with the gender other than men
for the purpose of the equity seeking
rule you will have received a piece of
yellow card stock during the
registration process so please raise
this piece of yellow card stock when you
arrive at the mic so that myself and
Adrian as chairs can identify you easily
if you don't have one there will be
additional uh cards available at the
mics as always if you require support
please flag a volunteer here and they
will be happy to assist
you as new Democrats we strive to create
inclusive spaces where everyone gets a
voice at the table there is also a
roving mic for anyone with accessibility
needs um so please um you know I think
we we have set up almost everyone who's
got accessibility needs but if not
please raise your hand and someone will
come and help you what about the
agoraphobia who couldn't who couldn't go
out to the to the conference in the
first place do they have a roving mic
that roves into people's homes I hope I
mean and what is racialized person well
they racialized also they started the
lgbtq acronym begins now with 2s which
just no it's 2s it's stands for two
spirit which just in case people don't
know and I've written about this before
my sub is literally an invention from a
conference in the
1980s Okay so
who are these people uh it's actually we
got it wrong it is the new Democratic
Party of Canada I
believe I'm not sure doesn't matter okay
speaks for itself um she she does anyway
yes she does well so I there are a
couple of observations first of all I
this this now yes I couldn't resist this
caused me to want uh somebody to put on
a comedy routine and the comedy routine
would involve a set that looks exactly
like that with a person that looks
exactly like her and would say exactly
what she said in exactly the way she
said and I think it will be hilarious
um but I mean the and my other thought
was what is this how will you find the
talent to pull that off though
impossible but nonetheless I Can Dream
that's a thought experiment so you know
it's got a big budget I hope so um but
it strikes me that what am I looking at
this seems like this seems like the
orientation to Utopia right that that's
what the orientation to Utopia would
sound like right and unless you're a
what was it a gender identifying as male
or a something something gender yeah
unless you're yeah I I if you if you
identify as a gender other than mail
then you can speak and it involves
something about a yellow card papers
paper right um my other thought which it
occurred to me as I was watching it was
reminding me there was something in the
back of my head I couldn't get out like
this reminds me of something what does
it the movie Brazil maybe no okay it's
the movie bananas oh so for those who
don't know I feel like I must have
spoken about this somewhere but uh back
in the early days we got our first VCR
we had a few tapes I don't know where
they came from one of them was the movie
bananas and so I must have seen it a
dozen times but you're talking about
your childhood home oh yeah okay yeah
yeah um anyway bananas was a Woody Allen
movie in which um Woody Allen the neishi
uh same character he always play same
character he always plays is trying to
get laid and the woman that he
encounters who becomes the focus of his
intentions is uh a deeply committed
liberal who uh is impassioned about a a
revolution in a fictional Latin American
country it's Dian Keaton and bananas is
his is his I think so and so anyway he
ends up through a series of events uh in
uh San Marcos the country and drafted in
he becomes a highly placed person in the
Revolution and the revolution does
manage to uh eliminate the dictator the
revolution about which he cares not at
all he's just trying to get into D kon's
pants just trying to get late right um
and uh anyway there's a scene where the
general who is a decent character until
the revolution wins is addressing the
population of the country in the
aftermath of his victory and he says uh
by the way please forgive me for this
it's even worse than my singing but he
says citizens of San
Marcos I am your new president from this
day on the official language of s Mar
Marcos will be
Swedish silence nobody has said
anything he says
[Laughter]
that all children under 16 years old are
now 16 years
old
citizens be required to change their
underwear every half
hour underwear will be worn on the
outside so we can
check and then the command his second in
command says from off camera power has
driven him mad well that is what even
the cadences of this woman describing
the rules of whether or not you get to
talk at this conference of new Democrats
in Canada reminds me so it just sounds
like this speech power has driven them
mad yeah
no
ass oh yep man um underwear will be worn
on the outside so so we can
check yep that's where we are
that that is where we are that is where
we are terrible yeah but H but
somehow well actually you know what I
mean forgive me for this too but
um because of a very dire multi-
Millennium history of Oppression and
genocide and
anti-Semitism Jews are weird um and the
ability to
um laugh in the most dire of
circumstances is uh is important and one
doesn't want to abuse it but but I think
uh the recognition that this is a
terrible terrible moment in history for
many reasons that are some obvious and
some less so but um but anyway uh we
need every tool at our disposal to get
through it and that
includes um that includes
humor I hope I'm an honorary Jew for the
for the moment then well one of these
days we are going to get to a discussion
about the way culture works and you not
an honorary Jew you have picked up many
Jewish characteristics and frankly uh
most modern Jews have picked up
characteristics from other populations
too that have altered the fundamental
rules of how we interact with each other
this is the nature of Being Human I
guess I will say one one more thing I
um I spoke this morning with my oldest
dearest friend um who like you is
ashkanazi
Jewish um and she has family in uh
Southern Israel near Gaza
uh and they're
alive uh but one of the things she said
to me was without having heard anything
that you had said or I had said you know
she's been staying out of media as I
think is
healthy
um it was God it was it was such a so
much like what we were talking about on
the last shows she said um I was talking
about our upcoming
travels on business and uh you know I
have to just flip a switch I have to do
something different and she
said yes this is all what is happening
in Israel is all that most many of us
can think about and many of us have have
loved ones who are in danger or um or
who have actually been harmed
um but if we allow ourselves to only do
that then they have one
and so there are other things that we
need to do in the world there are other
things that we are about in the world
and if
we uh imagine that the only work that we
can do right now is hold that space for
the people who are suffering and think
about nothing else uh then Hamas won and
no one wants Hamas to win noas must be
ended it must be destroyed and
uh the world will be better off and I
hope it happens
soon
indeed all right um we are going to do a
Q&A today um it's going to be somewhat
brief but we'll be back in 15 minutes
and then uh we're not going to have
another live stream for a little over
three weeks three weeks from tomorrow
we'll be back um but we'll be we'll be
showing up on locals at least uh at
least once or twice um from from from
other places and uh there will be some
great guest best episodes uh dropping in
the interim so tune in to those and if
you have not uh listened to the um I
never remember uh her whole name ephrat
fenon fenon ephrat fenon episode the
conversation that you had with ephrat
last week um please consider doing that
it's it's very very
powerful um check out our new store
blueberries because oxident happen um
Jake's micro pizza I'll put on a mask
when I'm done eating yeah
yeah fizer breakthoughs never
stop um and and and much much others as
well dark that's Darkhorse store.org
um you can ask questions for the
upcoming question the Q&A at Darkhorse
submission.com and um and you we we've
got lots of places to to find us um my
Natural
Selections uh my set my substack uh but
really the place that we'd love for you
to to come if you're looking for a place
to be able to find us and and help
support us is uh join the rumble Channel
um and um join us on locals and on
locals there's access to a lot of stuff
we've got a private monthly Q&A we do um
amas from uh time to time we're
releasing the guest episodes a day early
uh on uh for no sometimes sometimes I'm
I'm told by our producer uh and you can
access the Discord Channel there uh so
lots of great stuff and I feel like I'm
forgetting all sorts of things uh
consider uh our sponsors this week the
wellness company Hillsdale College and
uncruise and remember to like subscribe
share and talk talk with one another
talk with people you think you're going
to disagree with talk with people you
think you're going to dis you're you're
going to agree with and maybe find uh
that the opposite is true in both cases
and that you can learn from one another
regardless so until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside see you soon